last year a Destiny 2 player was sued by
the developer Bungie for over 100 cases
of cheating and for harassing their
staff during this time he threatened to
burn down the company's offices and
inflict violence against the devs
themselves as cheaters go this might
just be the worst of them all
I have a question for you what is the
actual punishment for Cheating in game
seriously unless a game can successfully
hardware Ban a cheater which is
something very hard to do they're almost
always going to find a way to come back
with a new account and even if they do
get fully banned from a game what
they're not just gonna hang up their
gloves and move on with their lives
these are attention Seekers and my guess
is that they're just going to move on to
another game since they know that there
are no real consequences right well this
is where we get to the story of Luca
Leone the scourge of Bungie on top of
blatantly hacking and live streaming
himself doing it Leon has been able to
navigate through his many bands over the
years by making at least 13 new accounts
and Bungie just couldn't get rid of him
making Leon the prime example of this
larger issue surrounding cheaters that I
speak of except 10 times worse you see
on top of the repeated cheating offenses
and allegedly selling stolen in-game
Destiny 2 items Leon was constantly
harassing Bungie and even specific
employees sometimes with violence and
since deleted tweets Leon claimed he was
moving to Seattle where Bungie is
situated and offered to commit arson on
their headquarters Leon also tweeted
several times about a specific employee
he posted a photo of that employee's
work badge claimed that he'd moved
within 30 minutes of them and that they
were quote not safe suffice to say
Bungie was dealing with a complex
situation and didn't have very many
options so they sued Leo on July 15 2022
they filed a complaint against him for a
Litany of violations including breach of
contract fraud and copyright
infringement if you're wondering how
these charges apply here every Destiny 2
player needs to agree to a legally
binding limited software license
agreement that prohibits things like
cheating which Leon broke many times
additionally since Leon continuously
made new account ounce to cheat with
accepting the agreement each time he had
no intention of ever honoring the
contract which Bungie claims is serial
fraud Bungie also accused Leon of
selling quote presumably stolen social
media accounts and in-game items that
are non-transferable which is again in
violation of that license agreement in
the complaint filed in Washington state
Bungie also brought to light the
numerous threats made towards the
company and its employees among other
accusations now if you're wondering what
the hell is Bungie asking for well on
top of straight up Banning this kid from
Ever playing a bungee game again they're
asking for a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars for every instance of copyright
infringement on top of that they also
seek 2500 for every instance Leon
actually used cheating software in
Destiny 2. before we move on I should
probably point out that this is hardly
the first time a developer has taken
legal action against cheaters how Bungie
does it all the time except it's usually
against the developers or sellers of
cheats and not just a singular person
that being said Bungie are sort of
expert it's on suing the shirt of people
that try to with them and in the
case of Leon just last week the lawsuit
came to what is called a consent
judgment meaning the judge came to a
ruling in which both parties Bungie and
Leon agreed to in short the court found
that Leon did in fact engage in cyber
stalking that arguably goes against
Washington's cyber crime act they also
found that Leon infringed on Bungie's
copyrighted Works twice now I know what
you're thinking out of all things how
does this still somehow come back to
copyright infringement well get this
since his cheats created its own digital
overlay they say that Leon was
technically making a derivative of
Destiny 2's original audio visual work
the second infringement is because the
software he uses injects its own code
into the existing code allowing him to
hack yes just like the audio visual
aspects of the game the code holds its
own copyright so it may seem wild but
those were technically copyright
violations he was making Leon was also
found responsible for two thousand
dollars worth in Damages each time he
circumvented Bungie's rules this
includes things like making new accounts
bypassing anti-cheat and so on the
document claims that Leon committed this
offense at least 100 times resulting in
an extra two hundred thousand dollars in
Damages bringing the now total to five
hundred thousand dollars on top of that
Leon can never play a Bungie game ever
again and is banned from being within a
thousand feet of a Bungie office or any
employee residence which honestly fair
but holy there is a lot to
unpack here listen this is a very very
unique situation involving what is
clearly a troubled individual and bottom
line Bungie needs to protect their
employees but many online saw this as a
significant exercise in power and the
law by Bungie if this President is taken
to the logical extreme would harmless
mods also fall under copyright
infringement once again although this is
a very extreme case of going against the
rules where does the line get drawn in
the aftermath Leon has started tweeting
again and he seems to not be taking this
all that seriously but where things
currently sit he will be responsible for
paying Bungie that five hundred thousand
dollars in Damages they were rewarded
with Leon accepting the terms of the
court case it seems like things are
finally concluded but if anything
changes I'll be here to let you know in
the aftermath many people are relishing
in the fact that a cheater is finally
facing real life consequences but I
think time will only tell if suing
people is the most effective form of
antichi
will you get banned for making UI mods
or harmless mods is something I saw a
lot on Reddit and honestly I spoke to
our lawyer just to pick his brain about
a few things but yes they technically
could but I would obviously be bad for
business if someone's modding a game or
adding UI elements to it that is
harmless they're usually not going to
want to make that heat on themselves
because like they're going to look like
complete but this is a very
very separate situation because a
they're cheating and be there for asking
out of their employees so I think you're
safe if you want to make every player in
Destiny look like Homer Simpson if you
want as long as it doesn't change the
hitboxes go ahead